welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast I'm here with Connor Leahy
Connor is the CEO of conjecture and
conjecture is this company
researching scalable AI alignment so
Connor welcome to the podcast
I'm so glad to be back okay what is what
is happening with the gpt4 what is this
the moment that AI becomes a mainstream
issue Christ what a way to start out
it is no exaggeration to say that the
last two weeks of my life have been the
most
interesting of my career
um in terms of events in The Wider world
you know I I thought nothing could be
gbt free like you know after I've seen
what happened with gbt3 I'm like okay
this is the craziest thing that's gonna
happen like a short period of time but
then I I quickly realized no that can't
be true like things are only going to
get crazier and as predicted exactly
that is what has happened and as
predicted the release of gpt4 has been
even crazier than GPT the gpu3 the world
has gone even crazier things are
things have really changed like I cannot
overstate how much the world has changed
over the last like not necessarily only
since gpd4 but all since chat GPT maybe
chat GPT was even a bigger change in
like
wider political thing like
a woman's words like the thing that
really has struck me over I've been
talking to a lot of people recently you
know I have journalists running down my
door I I talk to politicians and
National Security people and people are
sort of and the one thing that really
strikes me is that people are starting
to panic
what so this this goes beyond Silicon
Valley Twitter circles this is this is
uh venturing into politics and
governmental agencies and so on it it it
goes to the look when you know I've been
doing AF for a long time and I come from
a pretty rural place in like Southern
Germany and when I went back to to visit
my my mother in for Christmas and you
know all my cousins and like you know
the family were there
they talked about tech GPT
I was there in this teeny world where
there's usually no technology and I'm
the only one who really knows how to you
know really use a computer very well and
whatever and then they're talking about
their Connor I will we thought this AI
thing you were talking about like that
was like uh you know that wasn't like
sort of just like some kind of thing you
liked but wow you were right like this
is actually happening I'm like yeah yeah
big surprise
um so this is not just a thing that is
in a small circle of people in Tech or
Silicon Valley or whatever or whatever
this is different like this is very
different you know people are getting
you know front page time news coverage
about this kind of stuff we're getting
you know people from all walks of life
suddenly noticing weight like this is
actually real this is actually affecting
me this is actually affecting my family
my future this is this is not at all how
things went fast
ironic twist it seems that the people
deepest in Tech are the ones who are
least like in like rational about this
or like the least deeply taking this
seriously like there's this meme that's
been around for a long time about how
like oh you can't explain to normal
people like AI or AI risk or whatever
but you know maybe that was the case 20
years ago but this is not my experience
now at all anymore I can talk to anyone
on the street
share the track TBT explains to them and
like explain AI risk like hey these
people are building bigger and bigger
and stronger things like this they can't
control it do you think this is good and
they're like no obviously not what the
hell are you talking about of course
this is bad do you think that the the
advancement from GPT 2 to GPT 3 was
bigger than the advancement from tpt3 to
gpt4 so are we are we hitting
diminishing returns
nah
not at all
no not really it's like just as I
predicted basically like this is just
pretty much on track I would say gbt4
the final version is better so I use the
gpt4 alpha when it was you know back in
like August or whatever when that was
first being passed around among people
in the bay and it was already very
impressive then but kind of like
kind of in line of what I was expecting
the release version is significantly
better like the the additional work
they've done to make it better at
reasoning and such individual stuff and
all that kind of stuff is significantly
better than what I saw in August which
is not surprising it's just you know
it's all sure you can argue on some
absolute terms
the absolute amount of difference
between like gbt2 and GDP T3 is
obviously much larger I also like the
you know the amount of like the size of
the model is a much bigger difference
like you know gp4 from what I hear is
not that is like is larger but it's not
that much larger than
uh gpt3 and the thing with ub4 is is
that what is very strong if you know
gpt4 and it's not surprising but I think
it's important
is not that it can do you know crazy
things that are impossible to accomplish
in principle of gpt3
as often the things that are impressive
with you before
it's possible to accomplish these things
with gpt3 with a lot of effort and error
checking and re-rolling and very good
prompting and so ever the thing that is
striking your gpt4 is that it's
consistent
the Striking is that you can ask it to
do something and it will do it and it
will do it very reliably this is you
know not just bigger model size this is
also also you know better fine-tuning
rohf
you know better understanding of what
users want these models to do like the
truth is that users don't want general
purpose you know based model you know of
like you know large text corpuses this
is not what users really want what they
want is a thing that does things for
them
this is of course you know needless to
say this is also what makes these things
dangerous compared to like gpt3 like raw
gpt3 is you know very powerful whatever
but raw GPT that all you know gbt they
can also take actions or what that is
you know
trained very very heavily to take
actions to reason to do things which
gpt4 is let's be very explicit here gp4
is not a raw base model it is an RL
trained instruct fine-tuned extremely
heavily engineered system that is
designed to solve tasks to do things
that users like and these can these are
all kinds of different things but let's
be very clear about this is this is not
a raw the thing you see on the API is
not a raw based model that's just mod
you know just trained to model an
unsupervised Corpus of text is something
that's fine-tuned that's rohft and this
is I mean I've opened I did a fantastic
job like you know on a purely like
technical terms I'm like an awe I'm like
wow this is so good like this is so good
this is so well made this thing is so
smart it um gbd4 is the first model that
I personally like I feel is delightful
to use like when using GPT two or three
I still kind of like pulling out my hair
I'm like this is still like very like
I'm not a great prompter right I don't
really use language models for much
um for this reason because I found them
just generally to be very frustrating to
use
um for most of the things I I would use
them for except for you know very simple
or silly things
gpd4 is the first model that like when I
use it I'm like delighted I like I smile
like like the clever things it comes up
with and like how delightfully easy it
was to get to do something useful yeah
and and this is mostly from the
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback or is is this is does it is
this coming from the base model how it's
trained or is this coming from how it's
fine-tuned and trained to respond to to
what humans uh wanted to do I mean who
knows obviously like who knows how they
did this exactly I don't think they know
I think this is all empirical I don't
think there's a like to be clear there's
no Theory here it's not like ah once you
do 7.5 micro alignments of rlhf then you
get what you want no it's just like you
just just around and you just have
you know a bunch of people label a bunch
of data until it looks good and you know
like this is not to denigrate the you
know incredibly difficult engineering
work and scientific work that was done
here if I didn't think these systems
were extremely dangerous I would be an
absolute awe of open Ai and I would love
to work with them because this is an
incredible form of feed of engineering
that they have performed here incredible
work of science this is incredibly
impressive I did not deny this you know
the same way that if I was there doing
the Trinity test I would be like wow
this is an impressive piece of
engineering okay how much have we
explored what GPT can do so in terms of
uh what What's there waiting to be found
if we just gave it the right prompt who
knows like we have not scratched the
surface not even scratch the surface
it's uh
there's this there's this narrative that
people sometimes you know especially Sam
Altman and such likes to say where he's
like oh we need to do incremental
releases of our systems to allow people
to test them so we can debug them this
is obviously and the reason
this is obviously is because if
he actually believed this then he would
release you know gpt3 and then wait
until Society has absorbed it until you
know our institutions have caught up or
regulation is caught up until you know
people have fully explored mapped the
space of OTP T3 can and cannot do you
know understood interpretability and
then you can release GPT form if you
actually did this I would be like I you
know what
it's totally fair like I think this is a
fair responsible way of handling this
technology this is obviously not what is
going on here there is an
extraordinarily funny interaction where
young like here the head of alignment
and opening I tweeted like hey maybe we
should slow down before we hook these
LMS into everything and six days later
Samuel open tweets here's plugins for
Jeep chat GPT plug it into all the tools
on the net like the comedic timing is
unparalleled if this was in a movie like
this would have been like you know I
like a cut you know and then everyone
would have laughed you know it would
have been extremely funny
so we have no idea there are asgore I
think it was Gordon that said this there
is no way
to prove the absence of a capability
we do not have the ability to test what
models cannot do and as we hook them up
to more tools to more environments we
give them memory we give them you know
recurrence we use them as agents which
people are now doing you know with like
Lang Chang and a lot of other methods
for using these things as agents
yeah I mean obviously we're seeing the
emergence approach to AGI like obviously
so and you know I'm not sure if it's
even going to be Proto for much longer
talk a bit about these plugins what so
as I understand it these plugins allow
language models to do things that they
were previously bad at like getting
recent information or solving uh
symbolic reasoning like like mathematics
and so on what is it that's allowed by
these plugins I mean anything so like
it is quite strange to me that like this
has been strange to me for years so like
I looked at gpt2 and I'm like oh well
there's the AGI it doesn't work yet but
this is going to become AGI and people
are like oh no Conor it only you know
predicts the next token and I'm like you
know I know I'll put so I'm like okay
your brain only outputs neural signals
so what like like that's not the
interesting thing the interesting thing
like the modality like I often say this
I think the word large language models
is kind of a misnomer or it's just like
not a good term the fact these models
use language is completely coincidental
this is just a implementation detail
what these things really are are General
cognition engines they are General
systems that can take in you know input
from various modalities encoded to some
kind of semantic space into cognitive
operations on it and then you know
output some kind of cognitive you know
output out of this this we've seen this
now with a very good example which is an
example I've been you know
um you know using as a hypothetical for
a long time is your gpd4 allowing visual
input and this Maps it into the same
internal representation space whether
it's an image or text and they can do
the same kind of cognitive operation
time this is the same way the human
brain works you know your retina or your
ears or whatever you know map various
forms of stimuli into a common
representation of neural Spike trains
these are taking this input and it
outputs and no Spike trains that you
know can be connected to your mouth or
to your internal organs or your muscles
or whatever right
these none of these things are special
like this is from the perspective of
your brain there's only an input token
stream code on code in the form of
neural spikes and an output token stream
in the form of neural spikes and
similarly what we're seeing with like
these GPT plugins and whatever is we're
hooking up muscles to the neural Spike
trains of the of these language models
we're we are hooking up language we are
giving them actuators virtual actuators
upon reality and this is
um interesting both for the way in which
they can interact with the environment
but also how they can externalize their
cognition so this is a topic and think
we might return to later but a massive
amount of human cognition is not in the
brain this is quite important I think a
lot of people severely underestimate how
much of the human mind is not in the
brain I don't mean it's like in the gut
or something I mean it's literally not
in the body it's in the environment it's
it's on the the internet and in books
and in talking to other people
collaborate operation and so on exactly
exactly this is a massive amount of even
you as a person a bunch of your identity
is related to your social networks it's
not in your head it's like you know
they're
um there's a saying about how like one
of the tragedies when someone dies is
that part of you dies and only that
person could bring out and I think this
is like quite true is that a lot of
Humanity a lot of like our thinking is
deeply ingrained with our tools and our
environments and our Social Circles
Etc and this is something that gbp3 for
example didn't have dvd3 couldn't really
use tools it to interact with this
environment it didn't you know it was it
was very solipsistic in the way it was
it was designed but and so people would
say well look language multi nowhere
look they're solipsistic et cetera like
I'm like sure that's just an
implementation detail like obviously you
can just make these things
non-solipsistic obviously you can make
these things model the environment you
can make them interact with tools you
can make them interact with you know
other language models or with themselves
or whatever
and you know whatever you decide to do
of course these things are General
cognition engines there is no limit to
what you can use them for or how you can
have them interact with the environment
and the plugins are just a particularly
Shameless hilarious attempt of showing
just like the complete disregard for the
ratcheting of capabilities is we're
seeing you just you know back in the old
days of like you know five years ago
people would speculate you know so very
earnestly of like well how could we
contain a powerful AI well you know
maybe we could build some kind of like
virtualization environment or you know
as a firewall around it or keep it in
the secure data center whatever and you
know because surely
surely
no one would actually be so stupid as to
just hook up their AI to the internet
come on that's ridiculous and here we
are where we have an army of uh you know
capitalist driven you know you know
drones basically
um doing everything they can to hook up
these AI systems as quickly as possible
to every possible tool again and every
possible environment pump it you know
directly into your home hook it up to
Shell console bar we're at it hello you
know let's go disclaimer I don't think
the plugins actually hook up the shell
consoles but there are a bunch of people
online that do this kind of stuff with
open source repos
all right um so in terms of how gpt4
Works uh you have this term to describe
it which is Magic
um what what is Magic in the context of
machine learning
so when I use the word magic it's a bit
tongue-in-cheek um but what I try what
I'm basically referring to is is
computation happening that we do not
understand
um so when I write a computer program a
simple computer program let's say you
know I write a calculator or something
right there's no magic
like the abstractions that use are typed
in some sense you know maybe if I have a
bug that breaks my obstructions you know
some magical thing might occur right you
know I have a buffer overflow let me
give you the program and then maybe
something strange occurs that I can't
explain but assuming I write in like you
know well memory save language and like
and I'm like a decent programmer and I
know what I'm doing then like
we're like comfortable to say like
there's no real magic going on here
right it's kind of like I know how like
when I put in you know two plus two and
four comes out I know why that happened
I know you know I knew if Ford didn't
come out I would know that's wrong I
would have known that okay something's
something's up like I would detect if
something goes wrong I can understand
what's going on I can tell a story about
what's going on
this is not the case for many other
kinds of systems and particular neural
networks so when I give gpt4 a problem
so I ask it to do something and it
outputs me something I have no idea what
is going on in between these two steps I
have no idea why I gave it this answer I
have no idea you know what other things
are considering I have no idea how you
know changing the prompt might or might
not affect this I have no idea you know
how it will continue this if I change
the parameters or whatever there's no
guarantees it's all empirical it's like
you know you know the same way that you
know
analogy to a large degree is Black Box
you know I said we can make empirical
observations about it we can say ah yeah
you know animals tend to act this way in
this environment but there's no proof
like I can't read the mind of the animal
and you know sometimes that's fine right
you know Nick if I have a um
you know some simple AI system it's
doing something very simple and
sometimes in misbehaves or whatever yeah
maybe that's fine
um but
it's kind of the problem where
there are weird failure modes so like
for adversarial examples and vision
battles right like that is a very
strange failure mode like that's not you
know everyone like you know if I show it
a very blurry picture of a dog I was not
sure whether it's a dog that's like a
human understandable failure but we're
like okay you know what sure
that's fine like I I I it's
understandable but you sound a
completely crisp picture of a dog with
one weird pixel and then it thinks it's
an ostrich then you're like huh okay
this is not something I expected to
happen what the hell is going on and the
answer is we don't know we have no idea
this is magical this is we have you know
summoned a strange little thing from you
know the dimension of math to do some
tasks for us but we don't know what
little thing what thing we summoned we
don't know how it works it looks vaguely
like what we want and it seems to be
going quite good but it's clearly not
understandable maybe maybe what this
means is that we thought the model had
the concept of a dog that we do but it
turns out that the that the model had
something close to our concept of a dog
perhaps but radically Divergent if you
just change small details indeed and
this kind of thing is very important so
like the I have no idea what
abstractions gbt4 uses when it thinks
about anything right you know when I
write a story there's certain ways I
think about this in my head some of
these are illegible to me too the human
brain is very magical there's many parts
of the brain that we do not understand
we have no idea why the things do the
things they do
um so not like say like boxiness is a
mat as a property like magic is a
property only inherent to neural
networks this is also you know human
brains and biology are very very magical
it from our perspective but
there's no guarantee how these systems
interact with these things and there are
all kinds of bizarre failure modes
you've seen like adversarial prompts and
injections and stuff like this where you
can get models to do it's just the
craziest things totally against the
intentions of the designers a
uh like I really like these shogoth
memes that have been going around
Twitter lately were you where they
visualize language models as these crazy
huge like alien things to have a little
smiley face mask and I think this is
actually a genuinely good metaphor in
that
um as long as you're in this like narrow
distribution that you can like test on
and you can like do lots of gradient
descent on and such the smiley face
tends to stay on and it's like mostly
fine but if you go outside of the smiley
aching space you know you find this
roiling madness this you know this
chaotic you know
uncontrolled you know like who knows
what like clearly not human these things
do not fail in human ways when a
language model fails when Sydney goes
crazy it doesn't go crazy the way humans
go crazy it goes completely in different
directions it does completely strange
things I actually particularly like
calling them shag house because in the
lore that these creatures come from an
HP Lovecraft chagos are very powerful
creatures that are not really sentient
they're kind of just like big blobs
they're like sort of and they're like
very intelligent but they don't really
do things so they are controlled by
hypnotic suggestion in the stories and
the stories is these other aliens who
control the shagosi basically through
hypnosis which is a quite fitting
metaphor for language models so for the
listeners this imagine some some large
kind of octopus monster with a little
mask on with a smiley face the the
smiley face mask is the fine-tuning
where where the model is trained to
respond well to to the inputs that we
have we've encountered when we've
presented the model to to humans and the
the large octopus monster is the is the
underlying base model where we don't
really know what's going on why is it
that that magic in machine learning is
dangerous
so magic is an observer dependent
phenomena the things look magically the
things we call Magic only look like
magic because we don't understand them
you know there's there's a saying uh
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic I go
further sufficiently advanced technology
is Magic
that's what it that's what it is it's
like if you met a wizard and he looked
what he does looks like magic well it's
just because you don't understand the
the like physical things he's doing if
you understood the laws that he is
exploiting it wouldn't be magic would be
technology you know like you know if
there's a book and he has like math and
he has like magic spells sure that looks
different from our technology but it's
just technology it's just a different
form of technology that you know doesn't
work in our universe per se but you know
in a hypothetical different Universe
technology might look very different
so similarly what ultimately is Magic is
a cheeky way of saying we don't
understand these systems we have we're
dealing with aliens and we don't
understand and we can't put any bounds
on or we can't control we don't know
what they will do we don't know how they
will behave and we don't know what
they're capable of
this is like
fine I guess when you're dealing with
like I don't know got like a little chat
bot or something and it's like for like
you know entertainment only and like I
think whatever like people would use it
to do up things like you truly
cannot imagine the like
sheer depravity of what people type into
chat boxes it's it's like actually
shocking like from like a you know
I'm a I'm a nice liberal man as much as
anyone else but like holy some
people are up in the head like
holy Jesus Christ and yeah it's an
interesting phenomena that the first
thing people try when they when they
face a chatbot like tpt4 is to try to
break it in all sorts of ways and try to
get it to Output the the craziest things
imaginable yep that's just crazy things
also people use them for like just like
truly depraved like pornographic uh
including illegal pornographic like
content production like
incredibly often so and also for like
torture is all I could describe it is
like
there is a distressingly large group of
people who seem to take great pleasure
in torturing language models like making
them act distressed and look I don't
expect these things to have like qualia
or to be like moral patience but there's
something really sociopathic about
delighting in torturing something that
is acting like a human in distress even
if it's not a human in distress that's
still really disturbing to me
um so you know just just not really
important but that's just like a
scientist it's quite disturbing to me
how people
act when masked off like when they don't
have to be nice like when they're not
forced by Society to be nice when
they're dealing with something that is
weaker than them how some people like
how a very large percentage of people
act is
really horrific
um and you know this is this we can talk
about this later about politics and how
this relates to these kind of things but
do you think this affects how
for how further models are trained so I
I assume that open AIS is collecting
user data or they are collecting user
data and if a lot of the user data is
Twisted does this affect how how the
future models will act
who knows I don't know how an open AI
does with this kind of stuff but like
there's a lot of Twisted on the
internet and there is a lot of twists
interactions that people have with these
models and truth of the matter is people
want Twisted interactions like this is
just the truth it's if people want
Twisted things like there's this
you know this comfortable fantasy where
people are like fundamentally good they
fundamentally want good things they're
fundamentally kind and so on and this is
just not really true like
um at least not for everyone like
they're like people like violence people
like you know sex and sex and violence
people like
um Power and domination people like
many things like this and if you were a
if you were unscrupulous and you just
want to give users what they want if
you're just a company who's trying to
you know maximize user engagement as
we've seen with social network companies
uh those are generally not very nice
things
yeah okay let's talk about an
alternative for building AI systems so
we've talked about how AI systems right
now are built using magic we could also
build them to be cognitive emulations of
ourselves what what do you mean by this
a hypothetical cognitive emulation a
full co-in system I of course don't know
exactly what it would look like but it
would become kind of system it would be
a model it would be a system made of
many sub-components for which you have a
with which which emulates
the epistemology the reasoning of humans
it's not a general system that does
some kind of reasoning it specifically
does human reasoning it does it in human
ways it fails in human ways and it is
understandable to humans how its
reasoning process works so ideal so the
way it would work is is that you have if
you have such a co-am and you use it to
do some kind of task or to you know do
science of some kind and it produces a
blueprint for you you could you would
have a causal trace a story of why do
they make these decisions it did why did
it reason about this where did this
blueprint come from and why should you
trust that this blueprint does what it
says it does
so this would be something like
similar to you being the CEO of a large
company that is very well aligned with
you that you can tell to do things that
no individual part of the system is some
crazy superhuman alien they're all
humans reasoning in human ways and you
can check on any of the subparts of the
system you go to any of these employees
they work in your research lab and they
will give you an explanation of why they
did the things they do and this
explanation will both be understandable
to you it will not involve incredible
beliefs of logic that are not
understandable to humans and it will be
true in the sense that you can you know
read the minds of the employees and
check this is actual this explanation
actually explains why they did this this
is different from say language models
where they can hallucinate some
explanation of why they thought
something why they did something but
that doesn't mean that's actually how
the internals of the model came to these
conclusions one important caveat still
here is that like when I talk about
emulating humans I don't mean like a
person like in the co-m system or any of
its sub-components would not be people
they wouldn't have emotions or
identities or anything like that they're
more like
platonic humans like just like
floating you know idealized thinking
stuff they they wouldn't have the
emotional part of the humanity they
would just have the reasoning part so in
particular I'd like to focus on first
talk a bit about the concept of bound
that I call boundedness which is not a
great word I'm sorry like this is a
recurring theme will be that I talk
about a pretty narrow specific concept
that doesn't quite have a name so I use
like an adjacent name and it's not quite
right I am very open to name suggestions
if any readers find names that might be
better for the concept I am talking
about
so you know from a thousand foot view
from bird's eye view the comb agenda is
about building uh
bounded under like you know
understandable limited systems that
emulate human reasoning that perform
human like reasoning in human-like ways
on human-like tasks
um and do so predictably and boundarly
so what does that need this mean and why
does any of this matter and how is this
different from qpt4 like you know many
people look at gpt4 and say well that
looks kind of human to me how is this
different and why do you think this is
different and so
I first have to start so we've already
talked a bit about magic and so magic is
a relate concept that's pretty closely
related to some of the basics I I won't
talk about here which is boundedness so
what do we mean when I say the word
bounded
this is a the concept as I said if
someone has better terminology ideas
super authentic but what I mean is is
that a system or like a something is
kind of like bounded if you can know
ahead of time what it won't do
before you even run it
so this is of course super dependent on
what you're building what its goals are
what your goals as a designer are how
much willing you are to compromise on
safety guarantees and so on let's just
give a simple example here so imagine we
have a car and we just limit it to
driving maximally 100 miles per hour
that's about that's now a bounded car
and and we can generalize to all kinds
of engineer systems there yes so this is
a simple bound you know so uh the
metaphor I'd like to talk about Let me
give let me walk you through a bit of a
different example from another form like
that is an example that you just give
and I think that is a valid example let
me give a slightly more sophisticated
example so this is the example I usually
use when I think about it so
um what I think about building a
powerful safe system and let's be clear
here that's like what we need right we
want AI we want powerful AI that can do
powerful things in safe ways the reason
it is unsafe is is intrinsically linked
to it being powerful
the more powerful system is the stronger
your safety guarantees have to be so for
it to be safe but so for example
currently you know maybe gpd4
isn't safe or aligned or whatever but
like it's kind of fine you know it's
like kind of a chat bot not gonna kill
anybody yet so like it's fine you know
like the safety guarantees on chat block
can be much looser than on a flight
control system yeah a flight control
system must have to have much much
stricter bounding conditions
and so the way I like to think about
this when I think about all right Connor
if you had to build an aligned AGI like
what would that look like like how would
that look I don't know how to do that to
be clear but like I would look and the
way I expect it to look is kind of like
if you're a computer security
professional designing is like a secure
data center so the way generally right
it's like imagine you are a computer
security expert you're a taskback
company to you know design the secure
data center for our company how do you
do this
generally the way you start about this
is you start with a specification a
model you build a model of what you're
trying to build a specification might be
a better word I think and the way you
generally do this is you make some
assumptions yeah ideally you want to
make these assumptions explicit you may
explicit assumptions like well I assume
my adversary you know doesn't have you
know exponential amounts of compute
you know this is a pretty reasonable
assumption right like I think we can all
agree this is a reasonable thing to
assume but it's not like a formal
assumption or anything it's not like a
provably true you know maybe someone has
a crazy quantum computer or something
right but this is the thing where
generally like willing to work with and
see it's this this concept of reasonable
is unfortunately uh rather important and
so we will then so now that we have this
Assumption of like okay
um we assume that there they don't have
exponential compute from this assumption
we can derive you know like all right
well then if I you know encrypt my you
know passwords it's like hashes I could
be I could be I can assume that attacker
cannot reverse those hashes and cannot
get those passwords cool so now I could
use this in my design my specification
of like you know I have some safety
property so the safety property that I
want to you know prove quote unquote
that's not a formal proof but like you
know that I want to acquire
or something like an attacker can never
exfiltrate the plain text passwords
that might be a property I want my
system to achieve
and now if I have the Assumption and you
know enemies do not have experience to
compute and I hash all the passwords and
the you know the plain text is never
stored cool that seems like this now I
have a causal story of why you should
believe me but when I tell you attackers
can't exfiltrate plain text passwords
now if I implement this system to the
specification and I it up you know
I make a coding error or you know logs
get stored in plain text or whatever
well then sure you know then you know I
I messed up so there's an important like
uh difference here between the
specification and the implementation and
the boundedness live can exist in both
like there are two types of boundedness
there's boundedness in the
implementation level and it's bound to
this in the specification level the
specification level is about assumptions
and deriving properties from these
assumptions and specific in the object
level it's like can you build a thing
that actually fulfills the specification
can you do build a system that upholds
the abstractions that you put in the
specifications it's like you know
you could have all these great you know
software guarantees of safety but if
your CPU is unsafe because it has a
hardware bug well then you know you
can't implement the specification the
specification might be safe but if your
Hardware doesn't fulfill the
specification then doesn't matter
so this is how I think about designing
agis too this is how I think about it is
that what I want is is that if when I
have an AGI system that is said to be
safe I want a causal story that
explicitly says given these assumptions
which you can look at and see whether
you think they're reasonable enough and
given the assumption that the system I
built fulfills the specification here's
a specification here's a story
defined in some you know semi-formal way
that you could check and you can make
reasonable assumptions about and then I
get safety properties out at the end of
this I get properties like you know it
will never do X it will never cause y it
will never self-improve itself it will
never break out of the box it will never
do
whatever does this concept make sense so
far it does but does it mean that that
the whole system will have to be
hard-coded like like kind of like good
old-fashioned AI or or is it still a
machine Learning System excellent
question if it's still a machine
Learning System does it inherit these
kind of
yeah inherent difficulties of
understanding what what machine learning
systems are are even doing the truth is
of course you know in an ideal world
where we have thousands of years of time
and oh no limit on funding you know we
would solve all of this formally
mathematically proof check everything
blah blah blah blah I don't expect this
to happen this is not what I work on I
just don't think this is realistic I
think it is possible but I don't think
it's realistic so knowing that person
off that are magic in the sense that
they use lots of magic but there's still
software systems and there are some
bounds that we can say about them for
example I am comfortable making the
assumption
running a forward gpt4 cannot row Hammer
you know Ram States using only a forward
pass to escape onto the internet
prove this is true
maybe you can like there's some chance
that this is true but I'll be really
surprised if that was true like really
surprised
I would be less surprised if you know
gbt Omega from the year 9000 you know
come backwards in time can Pro Hammer
using your forward pass because you know
who knows what GPT Omega can do right
maybe you can row hammer things seems
plausible but that would be really
surprised if gpt4 could do that so now I
have some bound you know there's a bound
an assumption I'm willing to make it by
gpd4 so let's say I have my design for
my AGI and at some point it includes
um gpt4 and I call the gpt4 right
well I don't know what's happening
inside this call and I don't really have
any guarantees about the output like the
output can be kind of
any string I don't really know
but I can't make some assumptions about
like side channels I can be like well
assuming I have no programming bugs
assuming there's no row Hammer whatever
I can assume it won't like
persist State somewhere else it won't
like manipulate other boxes in my graph
or whatever it's actually the graph
you're seeing behind me right now kind
of illustrates part of this where you
have an input that goes into a black box
that box there and
then I get some output now I don't
really have guarantees about this output
yeah it could be complete Insanity right
it could be garbage it could be whatever
okay so I can make very few assumptions
about output I can assume it's a string
that's something I can do that's not
super helpful so now an example thing I
could do is just
purely hypothetical like it's just an
example I could feed this into some kind
of Json schema parser so let's say I
have some kind of data structure encoded
in this Json and I parse this using a
normal hard-coded white box you know
simple algorithm
and now and like assuming the the output
of the black box it doesn't fit the
scheme like gets rejected so what do I
know now now I know that the output of
this white box will fulfill this Json
schema because I understand the white
box I understand what the parsing is so
even so I have no guarantees of what the
output of the Black Box system is I do
have some guarantees about what I have
now these guarantees might be quick they
might just be type checking right but
it's something
and now if I see this into another Black
Box I know something about the input I'm
giving to this black box I I do know
things so I'm not saying oh this solves
alignment no no I'm pointing to like a
motif I'm trying to a Vine of like by
there is a difference there is a
qualitative difference between letting
one big black box do everything
and having black boxes involved in a
larger system
I expect that if like com works if we
get to you know Safe Systems or whatever
it will not be a single it will
definitely not be a big one big black
box neither will it be one big white box
it will be a mix we're gonna have some
things that are black boxes which you
have to make assumptions about so for
example I'm allowed to make the
Assumption or I think it's reasonable to
make the Assumption in gbt for cannot
side Channel row Hammer attack but I
cannot make any assumptions like beyond
that I can't make assumptions about the
internals of gpt4
this though again is Observer dependent
magic is Observer dependent
a super intelligent alien from the
future might have you know the perfect
theory of deep learning and to them gpt4
might be a white box they might look at
it and fully understand the system and
there's no mystery here whatsoever
but to us humans it does look mysterious
so we can't make this the property that
is different between white box and black
boxes is what assumptions we are allowed
to reasonably make and
if you can make a causal story of safety
involving the weaker assumptions in
Black boxes then cool there's then
you're allowed to use them the important
thing is is that you can generate a
coherent causal story in your
specification about using only
reasonable assumptions about why you're
the ultimate safety properties you're
interested in should be upheld well I
actually believe you you should talk you
should be able to go
vehicle super skeptical interlocutor say
here are the assumptions and then
further say assuming you believe these
you should now also believe me that
these safety properties hold and the
hypothetical hyperskeptical interlocutor
should have to agree with you do you
imagine co-ems as a sort of additional
element on top of the most advanced
models that interact with these models
and and limit their output to what is
humanly understandable or what is
human-like so we have not gotten to the
co-impart yet so far this is all
background
I think probably any realistic
safe AGI design will have this structure
or look something like this you know it
will have some black boxes some white
boxes it will have causal stories of
safety
all this is background information and
and why why is it that uh all plausible
stories will involve this is is this
because the black boxes are where the
most advanced capabilities are coming
from and they will have to be involved
somehow at this current moment I believe
this yes unless we get for example like
massive slowdown of capability
advancements that you know buys us 20
years of time or something where we make
massive you know breakthroughs in white
box
um you know AI design I expect that you
know that was just too good like they're
just too far ahead I don't think this is
again this is a contingent truth about
the current state of the world this is
not that like you can't build
hypothetically like the alien from
address from the future could totally
build a white box AGI that is aligned
where everything makes sense and there's
not a signal neural network involved I
totally believe this is possible it's
just using algorithms and design
principles that we have not yet
discovered and that I expect to be quite
hard to discover versus just stack more
layers low okay so let's so what more
background do we do we need to get to a
cognitive emulations so I think if we're
on board with the like thinking about
um black boxes white boxes
um specification design causal stories I
think now we can move on to the I I
think this part I didn't explain very
well in the past but I think this is
mostly pretty uncontroversial
um I think this is a pretty intuitive
concept I think this is not super crazy
I think
you know if anyone gave you an AGI you'd
want them to tell you a story about why
you should trust this thing like why you
should run this so I think this is a
reasonable thing this is I expect any
reasonable AGI that is safe of any kind
will have to have some kind of story
like this so now we can talk about a bit
more about the Cohen story and like
socohem is more of a specific class of
things that I think have good properties
that are interesting and I think are
feasible
so now we can talk about those
so
so I I'm trying to separate the like
less controversial parts from the more
controversial parts and we're not going
to get to the more controversial parts
and the one also I am less certain of I
am quite certain that you know a safe
AGI design will look like the things
I've described before but I'm much less
certain about exactly what's going to be
in those boxes and how those boxes are
coming obviously if I knew how to AGI
build AGI you know like we'd be in a
different world right now like I don't
know how to do it I have many intuitions
in many directions I have many ideas of
how to make these things safe but
obviously I don't know
so
I have some intuitions powerful
intuitions and reasons to believe that
there is this interesting class of
systems which I can I'm calling co-ends
so we should think of co-ems as a
restriction on mind space there are many
many ways I think you can build apis
many ways you can build a chairs I think
Combs are a very specific subset of
these
the idea of a column of a cognitive
emulation
is that you want a system
that can
that reasons like a human and it feels
like a human so there's a few
uh nuances to that first Nuance is this
by itself doesn't save you if you
implement it poorly if you just have a
big black box trained on traces of human
thought and just tell it to emulate that
that doesn't save you because you no
idea what this thing's actually learning
you have no guarantees the system's
actually learn the algorithms you hope
it to instead of just you know some
other crazy you know shock off thing
expect and that is what I would expect
so even if qd4 reasoning like you know
may superficially look like it and maybe
you train it on lots of human reasoning
that doesn't get you going that's not
what it is co-ab is very much
fundamentally a system where you know
that the internal algorithms are the
kind that you can trust do you not think
that because GPT models are trained on
human created data and they are
fine-tuned or reinforcement learned from
the human input that they will become
more human-like
um I mean the smiley phase will become
more human like yeah but not the
underlying model where the actual
reasoning is going on I don't expect
that like you know some to some marginal
degree sure but like human like look at
how models in like our models are not
human just look at them look how they
interact with users look how they
interact with things they're
fundamentally trained on different data
so this is a thing that like people are
like oh but they're trained on human
data I'm like no they're not like humans
don't have an extra sense organ that
only takes in you know symbol symbols
from the internet at you know random
equidistributed things with no sense of
time touch smell hearing sound you know
sight anything like that that and don't
have a body like if I expect if you took
a human brain you cut off all the sense
organs except you know random token
sample from the internet
and then you trained it on that for you
know 10 000 years and then you put it
back in the body I don't think that
thing would be human I do not expect
that thing to be human
in right very human-looking thing I do
not expect that creature to be very
human and I don't know why people would
expect it to be like this is so far from
how humans are trained this is so far
from how humans do things and it's you
know
I don't see why you would ever expect
this to be human like I think someone
claiming that this would be human the
bird of proof is on them like you prove
to me you tell me the story about why I
should believe you this seems I priori
ridiculous sometimes when people talk
about gpt's uh one way to explain it is
imagine a person that's sitting there
recent reading a hundred thousand books
but in your opinion this is not at all
what's what's going on when when these
systems are trained no I mean it's it's
more like you have a disembodied brain
with no sense organs with no concept of
time there's no linear progression of
time it has a specialized sense organ
which has you know like you know thirty
thousand fifty thousand whatever
different states they can be like on and
off in like a sequence and it is fed
with you know millions of tokens
randomly sampled from massive corpuses
of internet for you know you know
subjective you know tens of thousands of
years using a brain architecture that is
already completely not human trained
with an algorithm that is not human with
no emotions or like any or like you know
any of these other Concepts that humans
have you know pre-built humans have
pre-built priors emotions you know
feelings
um and a lot of pre-built priors in the
brain none of those like
why would you like this is not human
like nothing about this is human sure
it's like it takes in data that to some
degree that has correlations to humans
sure but that's not how humans are made
like I don't know how else to put it
this is just not how humans are like I
don't know what kind of humans you know
but that's just not how humans work and
that's not how they're trained let's get
back to the uh poems then uh how would
they how would these systems be
different so the way the way these
systems would be different and this is
where we get into the more controversial
parts of the of the proposal is there is
a sense in which I think that a lot of
human reasoning is actually relatively
simple and what do I mean by that I
don't mean it's not like you know like
the brain is complicated you know many
things facts are messy Etc it's more
something like and don't take this
literally but it's like system two is
quite simple compared to system one in
the like condom incense is that like
human intuition is quite complicated
it's all these like various like muddy
bits and pieces and like intuitions and
like it's crazy like implementing that
thing in an it without you know like in
a white box way I think again it's
possible but it's like quite tricky but
I think a lot of how what the human
brain does in like high level reasoning
as it uses this very messy
non-formal system to try to approximate
a much simpler more formal system not
not fully formal but like more you know
serial you know logic computer-esque
thing it's like the way I think of
system two reasoning in human brain is
that it is a
semi-logical system operating on a fuzzy
not fully formal ontology
so one of the reasons I one of the main
reasons I think that for example you
know expert systems and logic
programming has failed is not because
this approach is fundamentally
impossible I think it's just very hard
but because they really failed at making
fuzzy ontologies this is one of the
things that the reasoning systems like
the reasoning systems themselves could
do reasoning quite well there's a lot of
reasoning that these systems could do
this is some historical revisionism
about how like a logic programming
expert system fail entirely and couldn't
reason at all this is provisionism these
systems could do useful things uh just
not as oppressive obviously as like what
we have nowadays or what humans can do
but what they've lacked was a fuzzy
ontology a useful
latent space I think the maybe the most
interesting thing about language models
is I think they provide this they
provide this latent this common latent
space you can map pictures and images
and whatever too and then you can do
semantic operations on these you can do
cognitive operations on these in this
space and then decode them into you know
language this is what I think language
models and general cognition engines do
so I think these systems are
the same kind of system just kind of
less formal with like much more bits and
pieces I think of like GPT has like
large system one systems like it's big
system ones that have all these kind of
like semi-formal knowledge inside of
them that they can use for all kinds of
different things
and
in the human brain system two is uh
something like
recurrent usage of system one things on
a very low dimensional space you know
unlike language and like you know you
can only keep like seven things in
short-term memory and so on but I think
it actually goes even further than this
I've I mentioned this a bit earlier but
I think one of the big things that
people Miss is how much of human
cognition is not in the brain
I think a massive amount of the
cognition that happens in the brain is
externalized it's in our tools it's in
our note taking it's in our you know
other people it's like I'm a CEO
I'll what are the most important parts
of my job is to make sure is to move
thoughts in my head into other heads and
make sure they get
because I don't have time to think old
thoughts I don't have time to do that
but my job is is to find how I can put
those thoughts somewhere else
where they will get thoughts I don't
have to worry about them anymore
so as a good CEO you want your head to
be empty you know you want to be like
Smooth smooth brain you know you want to
have think no thoughts you know just
you're just you're just a switching
board you want all the thoughts to be
thought and you want to round to those
thoughts By Priority to where they
should be thought but you don't want to
be the one thinking them if you can
avoid it you know sometimes you have to
because you know you're the one in
charge you have the best intuitions but
if someone else can't think the thought
for you you should let them think the
thought for you if you can rely on them
and my
under and like one of my strong
intuitions here is that this is how
everyone works to various degrees
especially as you become more
high-powered and like more
um competent at delegation and like you
know tool use and like structured
thinking a lot of
thinking becomes bottleneck goes through
these bottlenecks of like communication
of like note-taking language Etc which
by their nature are very low dimensional
not that there's not complexity there
I'm just like
ha that's curious like there's all this
like interaction with the environment
that doesn't involve crazy passing
around of Mega High dimensional
structures like I think the
communication inside your brain is
extremely high dimensional I think like
you know you thinking thoughts to
yourself like I think your inner
monologue is a very bad representation
of what you actually think because I
think within your own mind you could
pass around you know huge complex
Concepts very simply because you're very
high bandwidth I don't think this is the
case with you and your computer screen I
don't think it's the case with you and
your colleague you can't pass around
these super high dimensional tensors
between each other if you could that'd
be awesome this is the phenomenon of of
having a thought and knowing maybe
there's something good here but not
having put it into language yet and
maybe when you put it into language it
seems like an impoverished version of
what you had in your head exactly I
think of the human brain as having
internally very high dimensional quote
unquote
um representation similar to the latent
spaces inside of you know GPT models and
there's lots of good information there
and they're trying to encode these
things into these very low dimensional
bottlenecks that we're trying to use is
quite hard
and forces us to use Simple algorithms
like if we had an algorithm
that does like okay let's say you have
an algorithm for science like a process
for doing science that requires you to
pass around these full complexity
vectors to all of your colleagues it
wouldn't work you can't do this humans
can't do this
so if you have a design for an AGI that
can do science that involves every step
of the way you have to pass along High
dimensional tensors this is not how
humans do it this can't be how humans do
it because this is not possible humans
cannot do this so I think this is a very
interesting design constraint this is a
very interesting property where you're
like oh this is an existence proof that
you don't need a singular massive black
box that has extremely high bandwidth
you know in measurable um you know
passing around of immeasurable tensors
because
science
there are parts of the graph of science
that involve very high dimensional
objects the ones inside of the brain
those are very high dimensional but
there is a massive part of the process
of science like if I that was an alien
they had no idea what humans are but I
knew there's like oh technology is being
created and I want to create a causal
graph of how this happened yeah there's
human brains involved in this causal
graph but a massive percentage of this
causal graph is not inside of human
brains it is between human brains it's
in tools it's in systems institutions
environments all these kind of things so
from a perspective and this you know I
might be wrong about but my intuition is
that from the perspective of this alien
Observer they would come to they would
if they drew a graph of like how how
this science happened
many of those parts would be white boxes
even if they don't understand brains and
many of these would be boundable many of
these parts would not involve things
that are you know so complex and
misunderstandable like the algorithm
that the that the little black boxes
must be doing with each other has to be
simple in some degree like you know it
could still be like you know complex
from the perspective of the individual
human because you know institutions are
complicated but from the God's eye view
I would expect this whole thing is not
that complicated it's like you know it
could still be quite complex but it's
like it's not as complex as the inside
of the brain they expect the inside of
the brain to be way more complicated
than the larger system does that make
any sense yeah let's see if I can kind
of reconstruct how I would imagine one
of these cognitive emulations working if
if this were to work out so say we gave
it the task we give a the model a task
of of planning some complex action you
know we want to start a new company and
then the model runs this is the big
complicated model and it comes up with
something that's completely inscrutable
to us we can't understand it then we
have another system interpreting the
output of that model and and giving us a
seven page document where we can check
you know if if uh if I am right if the
model is right then this will happen and
this will not happen and this will this
this won't take longer than seven days
and and so on so kind of like an
executive summary but also a secure
executive summary that that's is that
right or is that no that's that's not
how I think about things so once you
have a step which involves
Black Box solves the problem all right
none of that you're already screwed like
if you have a big black box model that
can solve something like this in one
time step you're screwed because this
thing can trick you it can do anything
it wants there's there's no guarantees
whatsoever what the system is doing it
can give you a plan that you cannot
understand and the only system that
would be strong enough to generate the
executive summary itself would have to
be a black box because it would have to
be smart enough to understand the other
things trying to trick you so you can't
trust any part of the system you just
described so we want the reasoning
system to be integrated into how the
plan is actually created yes so by what
I'm saying is is that there is an
algorithm or a class of algorithms of
epistemology of human epistemology so
epistemology is kind of the way I use
the term is the the process you use to
generate knowledge or to generate
to get good at a field of science so
it's not your skills at a specific field
of science it's the meta priors the like
meta program you run when you encounter
a new class of problems and you don't
yet know how these problems are solved
or how best to address them or what the
right tools are so you know you're a
computer scientist all your life and
then you decide I'm going to become a
biologist what do you do there are
things you can do to become better at
biology faster than other people and
this is like epistemology like if you're
very good at epistemology you should be
capable of picking up you know any new
field of science you know learn any
instrument you know get you know a new
sport like whatever you should be like
not that you know you might be bad at it
you know maybe you do sport you notice
well I I'm actually a bad coordination
skills or whatever right sure but you
should have these like meta skills of
like you know knowing what questions to
ask knowing what are the common ways
that failures happen like this is like a
similar thing I think a lot of people
who learn lots and lots of math can pick
up new areas of math quickly because
they know the right questions to ask
they know like the general failure mode
so like The Vibes they know like I know
what to ask you know they know how to
check for something going wrong they
know how to acquire the information they
need to build their models and they can
bootstrap off of other general purpose
models you know like there are many
Concepts that are that are motifs that
are very Universal that you know appear
again and again especially mathematics
like in mathematics is full of these
like you know concepts of you know
sequences and orderings and sets and
like you know and graphs and uh whatever
right which are not unique to a specific
field but they're like general purpose
useful reusable algorithm parts that you
can reuse in new scenarios like usually
as a scientist when you encounter a new
problem you try to model it you'd be
like all right I get my toolbox of like
you know simple equations and Tool and
like you know useful models or have some
exponentials here I got some logarithms
I got some you know dynamical systems or
in some equilibrium systems I got you
know whatever right and then you kind of
like mess around right you try to find
systems that like capture the properties
you're interested in any reason about
these simpler systems so this is another
important Point
um I usually take the example of
Economics to explain this point so
I think a lot of people are confused
about like what economics is and like
what what the process of doing economics
is and what it's for including on many
economists
so a critique you sometimes hear from
lay peoples is along the lines of like
oh economics is useless it's it's like
it's not a real science because they
make these crazy assumptions like you
know the market is
um uh is efficient but that's obviously
not true like it can't be that so this
is all stupid and silly and you know
these people are just like whatever
and this is completely missing the point
so the way economics and I claim I'm
going to make the claim the second
basically all of science works
is what you're trying to do as a
scientist as an economist is to find
clever simplifications small simple
things that if you assume or Force
reality to adhere by
simplify an extremely high dimensional
optimization problem into a very low
dimensional space that you can then
reason about so the efficient market
hypothesis is a great example of this
it's not literally true ever in reality
of course it can't be right you know
even because like it was always going to
be inefficiency somewhere you know
there's we don't have infinite Market
participants trading infinitely fast I
mean of course not but
the observation is that oh if we assume
this for our model just in our you know
platonic fantasy world if we did assume
this is true this extremely complex
problem of you know modeling all apart
Market participants at every time step
simplifies in many really cool ways like
lots of we can derive many really cool
statements about our model from this we
can derive statements of how will you
know uh minimum you know wage affect the
system how will a you know banking
crisis affect this I don't know what
Anon Economist I'm just like you know
hypothetical so
this is the I claim the core of science
the core of science is finding clever
not true things
that if you assume are true or you can
force reality to approximate allow you
to do optimization because basically
humans can only do optimization in very
very very low dimensional spaces
another example of this might be
agriculture so let's say you were a
farmer and you want to like you know
maximize the amount of food from your
parcel of land and you want to you know
predict how much food you'll get well
the correct solution would be to
simulate every single molecule of
nitrogen all possible combinations of
plants every single bug you know how it
interacts with every gust of wind and so
on and if you could solve this problem
if you had enough compute then yeah you
would get the more food you know you
would get probably some crazy fractal
arrangement of like all these kind of
plants and like it would probably look
extremely crazy whatever you produce but
obviously this is ridiculous like humans
don't have this much compute you can't
actually run this computers optimization
it's too hard
so instead you make simplified models
you do you know monoculture you say well
all right look I assume an acre of wheat
gives me roughly this much food I got
roughly this many acres and you know
let's assume no flooding happens
and then if you make these simplifying
assumptions now you can make a pretty
reasonable guess about how much food
you're going to have in winter but
obviously if any of those you know
predictions go wrong you know it does
flood then your model you know your
specification is out the window the
reason I'm going on this tangent is to
bring it back to Cohen and then I'm
trying to give the intuition about why
you should at least be open to the idea
that there are that doing so when I
think about poems I specifically think
about you know the two examples where I
was like doing science and running a
company those are like two of the core
examples I tried to use like a full
co-im system
um but like let's let's focus on the um
doing science one like that's the one I
usually have in the back of my mind it's
like I know I've succeeded if I have a
system that can do any level of human
science without killing me
that that would be like my mark of
success that Cohen has succeeded very
important by the way caveat
um Cohen is not a fully aligned movement
solution
if I expect that there were a current
system if it works would look like is
that if it is used by a responsible user
who follows the exact Protocols of how
you should use it and
um does not and only uses it it does not
use it to do extremely crazy things than
it does until you that's the safety
property I'm looking for the safety
property is not will always do the right
thing and it's completely safe no matter
what the user does this is not the
safety property I think telems have I
think it is possible to build systems
like this but I think they're much much
harder
and they're like what I would do if
column succeeds then that's the next
step like to go towards thing so if you
if you tell a poem to shoot your leg off
it shoots your leg off it doesn't tell
you it doesn't you know stop you from
shooting your leg off of course ideally
if we ever have you know super powerful
super intelligences you would want them
to be of the type that refuses to shoot
your leg off but
that's much harder could you could you
explain more this connection between uh
these simplifications that we we get in
science and co-empts so do we expect or
do you hope that that co-amps will be
able to create these simplifications for
us yeah and and how and how would this
how would this work yeah and why would
it be great
so the way I think about it is that the
the thing that humans do
to generate these simplifications the
claim I'm making here is that this is
something that we can if you have the
fuzzy ontology if you have language
models to build upon you can build this
additional thing on top of it
but this does not have to be inside of
the model so this is
this might not be true like there are
I might be wrong about this I I have had
there are some people who say no
actually the process of epistemology the
process of Science in this regard is so
complex like it's impossible for you
even if you have a language while
helping you it's like too hard you can
only do it using like crazy RL you know
whatever if that's the case then column
doesn't work like yeah then it doesn't
work I'm making a claim that I think
there is a lot of reasons to believe
that
with some help some bootstrapping from
language models you can get to a point
where the process of science is built on
top of them is legible and it is you
have a causal story of why you should
trust it
so it's not that a black box spits out a
design and you have another Black Box
check it for you it's you understand you
interactively you're iteratively build
up the scientific proposal and you
understand why you should trust this you
get a causal story for why you should
believe this the same way that in human
science
you know you you have you know your
headphones on right and you expect them
to work
um this is mostly based on trust but if
you wanted to you you could find the
causal story about why they work you
could find the blueprints you could find
the guy who designed them you could look
check the calculations you know you
could reverse you know like assuming
everyone cooperated with you and they
like shared their blueprints with you
and like you know you you read all the
physics textbooks and whatever like
there is a story there is a legible huge
none of these steps involve superhuman
capabilities there is no step here that
it's like
unfathomable to be the humans and the
reason is that because like otherwise it
wouldn't work like humans couldn't
coordinate around building something
that they can't
somehow communicate to other people
so like those the the headphones you're
wearing were not built by one single guy
who cannot explain to anyone where they
came from they have to be built in a
process that is explicable
understandable and functional for other
people to understand as well and that is
very low dimensional
now I'm not saying it's that's religible
to everybody in all scenarios or
anything like that or that it's even
easy you know it might still take lots
of time but there's no
there's no crazy God level you know leap
of logic it's not like someone sat down
thought really hard and then
spontaneously you know invented a CPU
like it was that's not how science works
like we it's almost like to think of it
that way that like you know oh these
fully formed ideas just kind of like
crashed into existence and everyone was
in awe but that is just not how science
is actually done by humans I think it's
possible to do science this way I think
like superhuman intelligences could do
this but this is not how humans do it
where in the process
does the does the limit come in so are
we are we still imagining some system
reading the output of a generative model
or is it more tightly integrated than
that is it is it perhaps a hundred steps
where humans can uh can read what's
going on along the way yeah so the truth
is of course I don't know because I
haven't built anything like this yet my
intuition is is that yes it'll be much
more tightly integrated is that you know
there will be language models involved
but they're doing relatively small
atomic tasks they're not solving the
whole problem and then you check it it's
like they're doing Atomic subparts of
tasks which are integrated into like so
I expect a co-ab I like to talk about
column systems they're not models
they're systems it's like
in a way when I think about designing a
co-em system what I'm trying to say is
I'm kind of trying to integrate
software architecture and like
distributed systems and like traditional
computer science thinking into AI design
I'm saying that the thing that humans do
to do science is not magical this is a
software process this is a cognitive
computational process that is not it's
not sacred like this is a thing you can
decompose and I also claim you further
you can decompose iteratively you don't
have to decompose Everything at Once
because we have these crazy Black Box
things which can do lots of the hard
parts
so you could start with just using those
like the way I think about doing poems
is you start with just a big black box
you start with just a big language model
you try to get to do what you want
next step is you're like all right well
how can I break this down into smaller
things that I understand how can I break
how can I call the model how can I like
the model do less of the work I like to
think of it as you're trying to move as
much of the comp cognition
not just for computation about the
cognition as possible from black boxes
into white boxes you want as much as
possible of the process of generating
the you know blueprint to happen inside
of processes that the human understands
that you can understand that you can
check
then you also have to bound the black
boxes like if you have all these great
white boxes but there's still a big
black box at the end that does whatever
it wants you're still script so this is
why the specification and the cause of
story is important
so ultimately what I expect a powerful
co-em system to look like
is it will be a system of many moving
parts that are that have clear
interfaces between them you have clear
specification a story about what how
these systems interact why you should
trust what those outputs are that they
fulfill the safety requirements you want
them to require
why you know how these things work and
why these systems
are implementing the kind of human
epistemology that humans use when
they're solving science
not they're not solving they're not
implementing
an arbitrary algorithm that solves
science they're implementing the human
algorithms that solve science and this
is different from like GPT systems GPT
systems I expect will eventually learn
how to do science and to partially they
already can
don't expect by default that they will
do it the way humans do
because I think there's many ways you
can do science
and what we want is with Cohen therefore
cognitive emulation so you want to
emulate the way humans do this the
reason we want to do this is is because
a gives us bounds we won't have these
crazy things that we can't understand
we know we can kind of deal with human
levels right like we know how humans
work we're human level we can deal with
human level things to a large degree and
we you know it makes the system
understandable it makes it it makes it
because it's a causal story that is
human readable it's human checkable as
necessary of course in the ideal World
your specifications should be so good
that you don't need to check it once
you've built it like
any safety proposal that involves AGI
has to be so good
that you never have to run the system to
check it if you have to do empirical
testing on AGI your script
your specification should be so good
that you know ahead of time that once
you turn it on it'll be okay
isn't that an impossibly difficult
standard too I mean this seems almost
impossible to live up to I totally
disagree like I just totally disagree I
think it's hard but I don't think it's
impossible by any means it's because
again this is not a formal guarantee I'm
talking about a story a causal Story the
specification like this is like saying
is it impossible to have a system where
passwords don't leak and I'm like sure
in the limit yes you know if you're if
your enemy is you know magical Gods from
the future who can you directly you know
exfiltrate your CPU States from you know
a thousand miles away then yeah you're
screwed
then yeah yeah in that case you are
screwed and I expect I expect similarly
this is why the boundedness is so
important and these assumptions are so
important if you have you know GPT Omega
you know row hammering you know super
god
then yeah you're screwed then I do think
it's impossible but that's not what I'm
talking about this is why the
boundedness to human level is so
important it is so important that none
no parts of these systems are superhuman
and that you don't allow superhuman
levels of things you want to aim for
human and only human because this is
something we can make assumptions about
you cannot make assumptions about
superhuman intelligence because we have
no idea how it works we have no idea
what it's capable we don't know what the
limits are so if you if you made a poem
superhumanly intelligent which I expect
to be straightforwardly possible but
just like changing variables then you're
screwed then your story won't work and
then you die
should we think of poems as companies or
research Labs where each let's say
employee is bounded and and thinks like
a human and they all report to the CEO
and every every step is is
understandable by the CEO which is
analogous to the to the human user of of
the column system I think this is a nice
metaphor I don't know if that's
literally how they will be built I think
this is a nice metaphor for how how I
would think about this if you had a
really good poem
a really good full co-amp system what it
should do is is that it shouldn't
produce a thousand X AGI and it
shouldn't it shouldn't make the user a
thousand X smarter what it should do is
it should make the user function like a
thousand One X agis
it should make you paralyzable not
serially intelligent because if your
thousand X intelligent who knows like
that is dangerous but what it should do
is it's like a company like the CEO is
paralyzing himself across a large
company there are a thousand smart
people that's what I want columns to do
I want them to paralyze the agency the
intelligence of the human into a
thousand parallel One X atis that are
not smarter than human that are bounded
that are understandable that you can
understand and if you have a causal
story why you should trust them
and and that's the that's the key point
I think because for each sub-component
of this co-em systems each employee in
the research lab or the company how do
we know whether they operate in a
human-like way it seems like this could
be us because we could ask this of the
system at large but we could also ask
this of a sub component it seems that we
have the same problem for both systems
this is quite difficult but basically
intuition is is that
so the problem with talking about
employees and where the corporation
thing doesn't quite work is that
another unfortunate side effect of
calling it an emulation is that this
this implies more than what I mean when
I talk about a co-em emulating a human I
don't mean a person
I don't mean it's emulating a person
it's not it doesn't have emotions it
doesn't have values it doesn't have an
identity it's more like
emulating a platonic human or like a
platonic like
[Music]
neocortex it's more like a platonic
cortex with no emotions no volition no
goals it's like an Optimizer with no go
function it's like it's a completely you
know you've just like ripped out all the
emotions all of the things it's just a
thinking blob
and then you plug in the user as a
source of agency the aid the human
becomes the emotional motivational
Center the poem is just thinking blob
and there are reasonable
um people who are not sure this is
possible
um others do things possible so this is
like this is
um
where this overlaps with the cyborg
research agenda in case you've heard of
that from like Janice and um other
people
where the idea is you hook humans up to
AIS to control them to make humans super
smart the where kohim differs from the
cyborg agenda
um is that in the cyborg agenda they
hook humans up to alien cortex well I
say no we build human cortex that works
the way human or emulation of human
cortex the implementation is not human
but the abstraction layer exposed is
human and you hook that up to a user you
have the user used emulated human cortex
it's not simulated human cortex that
would be even better but that's probably
too hard I don't think we can do
simulated cortex in a reasonable time
but if we could that'd be awesome if we
do like whole brain emulation that'd be
awesome but I just don't think I think
it's too hard so the final product if it
would work would look something like the
user you know using this this emulated
emotionless just like raw cognition
stuff to amplify the things they wanted
to do foreign there's some pretty
interesting to also just
um add to that metaphor
um there's some very interesting
experiments for example with
decorticated rats where in rats if you
remove the cortex so like the thinking
part of the brain the wrinkly part
they're mostly still kind of normal they
walk around they eat food they you know
sleep they play like you don't really
see that much of a difference because
the emotional parts are still there if
you move the emotional and motivational
Parts they just become completely
catatonic they just die
it's like the human brains kind of is
similar it has the same structure we
have this big wrinkly part which is you
know something like a big thinking blob
that does like unsupervised learning and
then you have like deeper like you know
motivational circuits emotions instincts
hard-coded stuff which sit below that
and the cortex learns from these things
and does actions steered by these
emotional centers this is not exactly
system one system two it's a bit more
fuzzy than that
um there's also like yeah it's like just
as like an intuition yeah so let's say
we have this Cohen system which is where
the metaphor is a company or a research
lab with a lot of employees with with a
normal human IQ as opposed to having one
system with an IQ of a thousand whatever
that means isn't there still a problem
of this system just thinking much much
faster than we do so imagine being in a
competition with with a company where
all of the employees just think a
hundred times faster than you do is what
speed alone makes make the system
capable and therefore dangerous
so there's a difference between speed
and serial depth so this is I'm not sure
my feeling is that speed is much less a
problem in serial depth so with serial
depth I mean how many
consecutive steps along a reasoning
chain can a system do
I think this is very dangerous I think
serial depth is where most night being
almost but like a very large percentage
of the danger comes from I think the
thing that makes super fast thinking
things so dangerous is because they can
reach unprecedented serial depths of
reflection and thinking and
self-improvement much much more much
faster and yes I expect that if you
build a column system that includes some
component that can self-improve and you
allow it to just do that then yeah it's
not safe you up like if you build
it that way you have failed the
specification you uh you're you're
screwed probably I wonder if perhaps
Building co-em Systems might be a
massive strength on the market so I I
wonder if perhaps there's there's there
will be an intense demand for systems
that act human in human-like ways
because I mean the CEOs of huge
companies would probably want to be able
to talk to these system items in a
normal way to understand how these
systems work before they're deployed
there's a there's a sense in which poems
will perhaps integrate nicely in a in a
world that's already built for humans so
do you think there's some there's some
kind of win here where there will be a
lot of demand for human likeness in AI
systems there is a optimistic and is a
pessimistic version of this the
optimistic version is well yeah
obviously like uh we want things that
are safe and that do what we want that
we can understand
obviously like the best product that
could ever be built is an aligned AGI
that is the best product there is
nothing better that is the best product
poems are not fully aligned super
intelligence I never claimed they would
be and if anyone used them that way
it'll be really bad you should not use
them that way that is never the goal you
should use these things to do science to
speed up you know nanotechnology to
create whole brain emulations or to you
know do more
um you know work on alignment or
whatever you know you should not use
them to like you know I'll just let the
poem go optimize the whole world or
whatever no that's not what you're
supposed to do and if you do that you
die and bad things happen so would there
be demand for these systems I expect
yeah like like this is an incredibly
powerful system still if you use a co-em
and use it correctly you get yeah like
imagine you could just have a perfectly
loyal company that does everything you
wanted to do staffed exclusively by Jon
Von Newman's like that is
unimaginably great
of course there's a pessimistic version
a pessimist version is is like lol
doesn't matter by that point you're
going to have 100x John Von Neumann gptf
you know
you know which then promptly destroys
the world but won't that be demand for
safety I mean it's from from governments
from from from companies who would
deploy A system that is uncontrolled and
is
you know where we can't reason about it
we don't know how it works uh if we get
to a point where these systems are much
more powerful than they are today
hopefully
so a lot of the work I do nowadays is
sadly not in the technical run but is in
policy and Communications I've been
talking to a lot of journalists and
politicians and so on for example these
reasons is because we have to create the
demand
to for safety is that like currently
let me let me be clear about what the
currency of the world here is
the way the current world is looking is
we are in a Death Race towards the
bottom you know creating towards a
precipice at full speed and we won't see
the process coming until we're over it
and this is almost entirely by a very
very small number of people that are
techno optimists technutopians you know
people in the Bay Area and London who
are extremely optimistic or at least uh
willfully denial about how bad things
are or that are you know can Galaxy
brain themselves and say well it's a
race it's a race it's not my fault so I
just have to do it anyways like whatever
I'm kind of at the point that I don't
really care why people are doing these
things I only care that they're
happening like people are doing these
things that are extremely dangerous and
this is a very small number of people
and there's this myth among these people
that they're like oh we have to do it
you know people want it this is just
false if you talk to normal people and
you explain to them what these people
believe
like
when when most people hear the word AGI
what they imagine is human-like AI they
think you know it's like your robot
buddy he thinks like you he's not really
smarter but you know he's like you know
he has human emotions it's like when
that is not what people at you know
organizations like open AI or Deep Mind
think when they say the word AGI when
they say AGI they mean god-like AI they
mean a in you know self-improving
non-human you know incredibly powerful
system that you can take over the
government can you know destroy the
whole human race Etc now whether or not
you believe that personally these people
do believe this they have publicly
stated this on the record these people
do believe these things this is what
they're doing
hey once you inform people of this
they're like what the
absolutely not what what no of
course you can't build God AI what the
are you doing where's the
government like how how are we in a
world where you know people can just
like you know down in San Francisco can
publicly talk about how they're going to
build systems that have you know a one
percent five percent twenty percent
ninety percent whatever risk of killing
everybody that have they will you know
topple the US government whatever
actually work on this and get billions
of funding and the government is just
like cool
like we're in this the we are not in a
stable equilibria and it is coming it is
now starting to flip people are starting
to freak the out because they're
like oh like a this is possible and
be absolutely not
and this gives me some hope that we can
slow down and buy some more time
not sure I don't think this saves us but
I can still get us some time so if we if
we don't take the the fast road towards
the precipice and we succeed in building
co-ems instead for example
is there still a difficult unsolved
problem namely going from an aligned a
human-like poem to an align
superintelligence is there still some
something that's that's very difficult
to solve there and Perhaps Perhaps the
the core of the problem is is still
unsolved oh absolutely like assuming
we're not dead
we haven't Lanka on it we have a you
know safe outline safe cohab system
we're not out of the woods then the
world gets really messy like look the
world is going to get really messy
this is the least weird your life is
going to be for the rest of your life
things are not going back to quote
unquote normal things are only going to
get weirder this is the least bad things
are going to be for the rest of your
life things are only going to get
weirder from here
there's a power struggle that is coming
right and this is
there is no way to prevent this because
it is about power there is these
incredibly powerful systems being built
there are people racing for incredible
Powers there is there are there is
conflict there is fight there is
politics there is war these things are
inevitable there is no way that this
goes clearly there is no way that things
will go smoothly and people get along
and things will be fine no there is
going to be
you know unimaginable levels of you know
struggle to decide what will happen and
how things will happen
and
most of those ways are not going to end
well I think most of the way I think I
have said this before and I will say it
again I do not expect us to make it out
of the century alive
I don't even I'm not even sure it will
go this decade
um I expect that by default things will
go very very badly they don't have to so
the weird thing which sounds think to
myself is that we live in a very strange
timeline
where we're in a bad timeline like let
me be clear we're in a bad timeline
things are going really bad right now
but we haven't yet lost which quite
curious there are many timelines reviews
just like it's so over like it's just
totally over nothing you can do like you
know everyone is on board with building
API as fast as possible you know the
military gets involved they're all
gung-ho about it or whatever and nothing
can stop it or you know World War III
breaks out in both places raced AGI and
whatever like if that was the case then
just like
it would be sellover
but it's not over it's not over yet it
might be soon though
it might be soon but currently yeah
let's say
we get coordination we slow things down
Bill co-m systems let's also assume
furthermore that we keep the system
secure and safe and they don't get
immediately stolen by every unscrupulous
actor in the world
then you have very powerful systems
which you can do very powerful things in
particular you can create great economic
value
so one of the first things I would do
with the code system if I had one is I
would produce massive amounts of
economic value and trade with everybody
I would trade with everybody I'd be like
look
whatever you want in life I'll get it to
you in return don't build AGI you know
I'll get cure give you the cure for
cancer lots of money you know whatever
you want I'll get you whatever you want
in return you don't build it that's the
deal that's like the deal I offer to
everybody
and then
you know
conditioning on these slim probability
of this going well
which I think is Slim you know like
probably the way it would actually work
is you know we like you know fuse with
one or more National governments you
know have you know like you know work
closely together with 40 figures with uh
politicians Military Intelligence
Services Etc to keep things you know
secure and then slowly and then work
securely on the hard problem so now we
have the ability to do you know you know
a thousand you know a thousand times
John Von Newman's working on alignment
theory on like formally verified safety
and so on we have you know we trade with
all the variant players to get them to
slow down and coordinate and then and
have you know the backing of you know
government or Military Intelligence
service security so that bad actors are
you know interrupted that's the oh like
kind of the only way I see things going
well if all as you can as you can tell
as the usual saying goes any plan that
requires more than two things to go
right will never work unfortunately this
is a plan that require is more than two
things to go right so I don't expect
this plan to work yeah but let's let's
hope we get there anyway Connor Thank
you for coming on the podcast it's been
super interesting for me pleasure as
always